will elon musk take over twitter the
billionaire has made a controversial
offer but he's facing many hurdles
what's driving musk's quest to own
twitter and what would a possible
takeover mean for this platform this is
inside storage
[Music]
hello and welcome to the program i'm kim
vinnell twitter's board has armed itself
against a possible takeover after the
world's richest man said he wants to buy
twitter billionaire elon musk has made a
43 billion offer he says the social
media giant needs to be taken private to
grow and to become a platform for free
speech
but the twitter board is fighting back
it's adopted a so-called poison pill
plan that will prevent anyone from
owning more than a 15 stake in the
company it allows others to buy
additional shares at a discount making a
buyout much more difficult
musk recently increased his stake to
nine percent making him twitter's
largest shareholder
musk calls himself a free speech
absolutist opposed to any restrictions
on what someone can say on social media
as long as it adheres to the laws of the
country where the platform is based he's
posted a series of tweets indicating he
thinks twitter is heading in the wrong
direction it isn't the first time musk
has railed against twitter claiming it
represses free speech that he partly
blames on the platform's reliance on ad
revenues
or news of the bid set the internet and
especially twitter on fire among those
responding was saudi arabian investor
prince al-waleed bin talal he tweeted
saying that as one of the major
shareholders in twitter he rejected a
takeover bid by elon musk he said i
don't believe that the proposed offer by
elon musk
54.20 per share comes close to the
intrinsic value of twitter given its
growth prospects
let's bring in our guests from notre
dame indiana indiana rather we have tim
hubbard assistant professor of
management at the university of notre
dame's mendoza college of business from
atlanta is jim anderson social media
sector lead at glass wing benches and
from new york william cohen founder of
puck news and former mergers and
acquisitions investment banker thank you
all very much for joining us here on
inside story i'd like to start with you
mr anderson let's start with what's at
stake here how important is twitter for
the public discourse and why is it that
this take over bid by elon musk has
sparked such intense reaction
yeah kim you know twitter has long
punched above its weight class if you
will it's important far seems to exceed
uh its performance financially it has
been a mediocre
investment i think most uh analysts
would say from a financial perspective
but it is embroiled in many of the most
consequential discussions around
politics the economy etc and so i think
in many ways elon musk is correct in
identifying wow this is an under
leveraged asset somebody could do more
with twitter so i don't think he's wrong
in going after it because it really is
an important part of what we do
tim hubbard elon musk has said that this
is about ensuring there's an arena for
free speech so we can all talk freely
within the bounds of of the law
do you think he's serious about this
takeover bid or do you think he's just
making a point
i think honestly he's making a point uh
if you stand back and you think about
what he wants twitter to achieve it's
free speech and and you know an open
platform for everybody and to move the
company in that direction i don't
necessarily think he needs to buy the
company instead even just showing that
it's possible to buy twitter puts
twitter in a position where then they
have to think okay how can we position
our platform how can we set the users up
in order to avoid the need for a
takeover by somebody like elon musk
william cohen in new york so far the the
board of twitter has responded by
triggering the so-called poison pill
plan
just explain to us what what that is
what it means
well what it does is it will allow
uh other shareholders to buy
shares of twitter stock
less expensively
than they're currently trading for in
the market
if
elon musk buys
around 15
of the
twitter stock now you know
these poison pills uh
are merely uh a way a
potential hurdle if you will for an
acquirer a hostile acquirer to buy a
company i don't think they've ever been
actually
invoked i don't think there's ever been
a time when shareholders have actually
bought shares of stock
in their company at a discount to try to
prevent a hostile taker over so what
they end up being is just a another
hurdle that a potential acquirer has to
get over and forces the potential
acquirer to deal directly with the board
of directors how do you think this is
going to play out then do you think uh
this will just be a hurdle for elon musk
i know he he tweeted rather cryptically
love me tender referring obviously to a
song but maybe also
to a tender offer
right i think
everything hinges now on whether or not
he can raise the financing
he already has spent 2.6 billion dollars
of his own money let's say he needs
another 40 billion
uh he obviously is the world well we
think he's the world's richest man uh
with uh you know
and so uh can he uh raise the say 40
billion that he needs
or the
say
uh you know assuming he can raise some
of it in debt maybe let's just say he
needs to raise uh can put in 20 bill
another 20 billion of his own money can
he raise another 15 billion dollars from
third parties to make this possible if
he can it's a game set match it's over
he'll buy twitter whether anybody wants
him to or not whether he wants to or not
uh uh if you can't raise that money then
it's a moot point does he have that kind
of money if he's the world's richest man
theoretically he does we don't know uh
how much he of his tesla stock which is
of course the foundation of his wealth
uh how much of that tesla stock uh which
is worth around 175 billion he has
already uh pledged or margined or
hypothecated uh to somebody else uh for
various loans to pay taxes to live his
life whatever it is that he does for
spacex or the boring company some of his
other projects it's not known how much
of that
he's already uh pledged so the question
is how much is left unpledged and at
what point does he risk uh his value of
in tesla to buy twitter i mean i think
he's a lot of things but i'm pretty sure
he's not going to risk what he's built
up in tesla just to buy twitter sure
uh jim anderson
he has talked to elon musk has talked a
lot about this the the take of the bid
being purely for the good of society for
the good of humanity almost um what
would what would lead him to to make
those sorts of statements what is it
that's going on behind the scenes at
twitter in terms of algorithms that has
become such an issue
well it's funny you know elon musk is
one of the most consequential
entrepreneurs of our generation probably
the past 50 years so i'll certainly give
him that but trying to understand what's
going on in his mind at any point is an
exercise in frustration you said he
tweeted love me tinder he did
if any of us think he was tweeting about
a song
you know let's let's not kid ourselves
we know he's playing a game right and
and he's he's clever he's he i think he
enjoys being uh difficult and
unpredictable uh and he's latched on to
you mentioned the algorithms and the
free speech those are the two things
he's latched on to and for such a smart
brilliant really man he's been
maddeningly non-specific about what he
really wants to accomplish in and around
free speech other than i advocate for
free speech and in and around algorithms
other than i advocate for opening up
algorithms both of those are enormously
complex topics that involve a lot of
subtleties and he has been maddeningly
non-specific i think the idea of owning
twitter is a lot more interesting to him
than the reality of owning twitter would
be
um tim hubbard would you agree with that
assessment
i completely agree that owning twitter
is is not as
uh luxurious if you will as as you know
fighting with twitter and proposing
buying twitter if we stand back and we
think about elon musk and what he wants
to accomplish in his lifetime he wants
to do things that are going to push
humanity forward and going to mars and
electrifying you know vehicles these
types of grand challenges are where
if he spends his time he can really
cement his legacy going and taking over
twitter and spending his time instead at
twitter is important yes for free speech
around the world but at the same time he
might view his time better spent
hopefully
trying to accomplish some of these big
big problems that only he is prepared to
tackle
um william cohen
twitter wants to double its revenues by
2023
with 315 million monetizable daily
active users as if we needed a reminder
that we are monetizable active users um
how ambitious are its plans how has
twitter compared to say facebook from a
profitability perspective
twitter is
woefully uh unprofitable i think you
know you said at the beginning of the
show
that it is not a great business it is it
is not a great business uh
you know it it has punched above its
weight
uh you know it
you know last last year you know if you
just
don't do the ad add-backs
uh which of course uh twitter would like
you to do
uh it made about you know 56 million
dollars of ebitda earnings before
interest taxes depreciation and
amortization which is of course the key
metric of profitability on wall street
now they had a 750 million dollar
legal settlement as part of that so if
you add that back
maybe they did something like 800
million of ebitda
in 2021 in previous years it was around
950 million you know somewhat less than
a billion dollars of ebitda i mean
you know i don't know i haven't looked
at facebook's uh
p l lately but they probably do a
billion dollars in ebitda you know in a
week
uh and so uh you know uh apple probably
does a billion dollars of ebitda in a
day that's an exaggeration of course but
you know
twitter is not a great a business and
one of the things that elon musk has
talked about in his tweeting leading up
to this offer or surrounding this offer
is that he wants to you know take ads
off the platform well you know that
might be great for the user experience
but it's going to decimate the p l of
of twitter so uh you know i don't know
how he can
propose taking this company private and
then decimating the p l could it be a
great company though mr cohen i mean
could it could it be a money-making
business i mean
with with elon musk i believe that uh
stocks and twitter are up more than 20
since elon musk disclosed his stake in
twitter on on april the 4th it's almost
like
just having him involved attracts
investment in tracks hype attracts
excitement
you know could it go on to do great
things
well the fact that he's made an offer
for the company in the stock price going
up is
is not the same as the company uh
generating uh you know profitability and
ebitda i mean you know could it be i
think a bigger problem is not could it
be a great company i think uh the bigger
problem is elon musk you know is that
like the dog that catches the car here
uh you know is he going to do things
that alienate uh many of the users uh
on twitter that make it relevant i mean
what makes twitter so relevant is the
great debate that takes place all day
every day if you know he does things
like uh you know bring back uh donald
trump for example he's going to alienate
something like half to two-thirds of his
users and they're going to drop off the
system and go somewhere else and he's
going to lose them and they aren't going
to be monetizable as you said so i'm not
sure exactly what he has in mind here i
don't i don't see his vision for this
company making it great
uh jim anderson as we we mentioned
earlier saudi arabia's prince alwaleed
bin talal is a major shareholder of
twitter um he said in 2015 that he he
had at that point a 5.2 stake now he has
tweeted his opposition uh to this
takeover saying that the offer doesn't
come close to the intrinsic value of
twitter do you think for him it's purely
a cash thing
or might saudi have pressured uh the
prince into opposition as as elon musk
actually implied when he tweeted what
are the kingdoms views on journalistic
freedom of speech is there more going on
there do you think
i'm sure there is more going on i mean
you know the all boards of directors
have their own intrigue and their own
dynamics and twitter's is somewhat
legendary for having you know inside uh
palace intrigue if you will so i'm sure
there's a lot of dynamics i i somehow
doubt for a lot of the people involved
here that is really about the cash
whether it be the kingdom of saudi
arabia or elon musk frankly you know
twitter this goes back to the point
we've made of twitter punching above its
weight class it is a really important
platform and you know there's a lot of
people who would be interested in having
either a
de facto control or absolute control
over what goes on over the moderation
decisions
that are made there and i suspect that's
a big a big chunk of the of the
opposition as well is just a sense that
wow if elon musk gets control of twitter
if he owns it especially if he then
makes it a lot more valuable then that's
not going to reflect well on the on the
previous board of directors who almost
certainly all will be pushed out uh and
and who did not unlock that economic
potential sure
tim hubbard you are an assistant
professor of management
how would you describe elon musk's
management style
i think he's the type of person that's a
problem solver i think he involves
himself in projects and in businesses
that are very technically advanced and
rather than shy away from the technical
problems that plague the technologies
he's trying to develop he brings
together a group of smart people that
are able then to tackle the problem in a
way that other companies just aren't and
so if we stand back and we think about
how he's able to reuse rockets how he's
able to
develop battery technology
that other companies just can't i think
his leadership style really is that
excitement it is that bringing to be
together people who are able to really
tackle these deep problems and that's
unique that's putting him in a position
where he's a bit of a visionary where
he's able then to control the discourse
but also as he's developing these
technologies in these individual
companies he's finding ways to then take
those uh technologies and use them in
other areas and other industries
in ways that weren't necessarily thought
of in the beginning and so his
management style is very much
bringing people together that are very
smart to tackle problems that are very
very complicated what about his
unpredictability though because if
you're a major shareholder in any of the
companies that he owns you know any of
his tweets anything he says in an
interview
under the influence perhaps you don't
you don't know what he's what he's going
to say or do next so i mean is that is
that not an issue
that is absolutely an issue
that's the noise if you will around the
the innovation and the foresight that he
has
you know if you stand back and you think
about chief executive officers if you
sit down with a typical ceo you're going
to ask them about an industry lookout
for a few years you're going to ask
about the company what they're going to
be doing in five years when you sit down
with elon musk though you ask the
question where is humanity going to be
in 2050 and that's a completely
different thing and so uh yeah the the
antics that he puts out are are very
disturbing at times they're very
controversial but at the same time the
core of what he's doing is really big
it's really trying to advance humanity
and so i kind of feel like at times yeah
we like to talk about those things but
at the same time we really should be
focusing on the good things that he's
doing and those are quite numerous sure
william cohen uh just speaking about
what elon musk has been tweeting he also
tweeted that jack dorsey leaving the
board of twitter meant that the board
collectively owns almost no shares in
twitter and therefore that and i quote
their economic interests are simply not
aligned with shareholders
does he have a point
absolutely
he has a point
aside from jack dorsey who's leaving the
board in may
uh jack dorsey has about 2.25
ownership stake in twitter the rest of
that board has way less than one percent
ownership stake
and so they don't
uh you know they are fiduciaries uh for
shareholders but in terms of you know uh
actually having any skin in the game
here they have
zero skin in the game and i would also
add for your viewers that prince
alwaleed who once upon a time may have
owned something like five percent of
twitter uh uh no longer does i'm not
sure what he owns at the moment i'm not
sure what uh how relevant it is that
he's tweeting about his view of of uh
elon musk's offer he's he's not involved
anymore and and he's not on the board he
has no influence he's not a large
shareholder so not sure why anybody
would listen to him at the moment
but the key here is
uh some of the big
shareholders that are out there which
are
a
big retail uh
asset management uh companies like
blackrock like morgan stanley like
vanguard which is the largest
shareholder at ten percent uh so i think
they're all likely to take if this
financing can be firmed up if if elon
musk can prove to
his financial advisor morgan stanley and
if he can prove to goldman sachs who is
representing
the twitter board and the twitter board
that he has this financing lined up then
those big shareholders vanguard
blackrock morgan stanley are going to go
and take this money and run
this is the best thing that's happened
to twitter in in in years
jim anderson
what would
let's just go down the road and imagine
what would a a twitter
with uh an elon musk having a
controlling stake what would that look
like what changes
could we see i mean i know he's included
a call to remove advertising and
dropping w from the name twitter but
apart from that i mean what could that
look like
so i think it would be wildly
unpredictable that that's maybe part of
the excitement i think when people look
at this as you you mentioned earlier wow
he's made twitter relevant in a way that
the topic of twitter not just what's
going on on twitter by other people just
the copy of the topic of the company and
the platform itself so i think that in
in many ways that would be a net
positive and would continue because
everybody's on the edge of their seat
wondering what elon musk is going to do
next i think pragmatically he has said
he he does not agree with the
advertising oriented business but as
william said i mean that's like 95 of
their revenue if anybody could pull off
a fundamental transformation of a
company's revenue model and saying we
are 95 ad dependent and i want us to be
five percent ad dependent in the next
say three years you know elon musk
that's the kind of big thing that he
could pull off and they could turn
subscription uh twitter into a
subscription business there's a lot of
other things they could do that are not
tweaking around the margins and trying
to get 20 growth but fundamentally
changing the nature of the company so i
would expect at least those things to be
under discussion for somebody like elon
musk again whether he has the time the
patience and whether that's a big enough
legacy uh as tim had said is that what
he wants to spend his time and how he
wants to leave his mark re rebranding
and re uh reformulating what constitutes
twitter i think that's the open question
tim hubbard where do you think this is
all headed does it at the very least
continue to bring to the fore the
question of free speech on social media
or how do we do we moderate speech on
social media to keep people safe to stop
information i mean how do you see this
playing out
yeah if we stand back and we think about
what's already happened we're having the
discussion on free speech right now and
i think even if he doesn't go through
with the the buyout of of twitter he's
already made a mark and already had
everybody stand back and think about
free speech and what it means and what
happens when a company decides to
regulate speech and a lot of times we
think of these social media companies as
firm companies that aren't going to be
changing very much and so if they take a
stance on free speech that might be
controversial a lot of times we kind of
just go oh okay yeah and we move along
our day
but at this point in time he's making us
stand back and look at twitter look at
these face facebook and other companies
that are working to regulate speech to
some extent and actually say well you
can actually you can come in and you can
change the firm you can buy out the firm
you can change the board of directors
you can change out management and
drastically change the position of the
company but is that just not then
putting another one man in control you
know if it's all about decentralization
and you know putting the the making
everything transparent is that not just
counter-intuitive when in fact what he's
looking to do is is have a controlling
stake
yeah i think and and one key thing you
know when having the controlling stake
is that a lot of the social media
companies you know the the interest in
them rises and and and falls at times
and so even if he comes in and he has
great visionary you know ideas and he's
able to make changes it doesn't always
mean that those changes are going to be
for the better so there's always a risk
in him coming in as well and that's
that's the hard part i think really to
gauge is what are the benefits but then
what are the potential risks in terms of
user base in terms of interest in
twitter uh it will definitely keep it in
the news and keep it something that
we'll be talking about but at the same
time i'm not sure that how users are
going to change their level of
interaction with the company going
forward sure we've got about a minute
left so i'd like to leave it with you uh
william cohen uh where do you think this
is headed what's your take
if uh elon musk can raise the capital
that he needs to prove
to the twitter board of directors and
goldman sachs that he has
the 40 billion dollars that he needs to
make his 54 and 20 cents an offer real
it's his company there's there's clearly
no one else coming along to buy this
company uh there's no question that
54.20
is you know a fair price for this
company i mean the 43 billion dollars
for a company that makes a billion
dollars a year in ebitda is plenty
generous plenty fair if he can uh
arrange for this financing and prove
that he's got it it's over
all right we'll leave it there thank you
very much uh for joining us gentlemen
tim hubbard jim anderson and william
cohen
and thank you for watching you can see
the program again any time by visiting
our website
and for further discussion go to our
facebook page that's facebook.com
forward slash aj inside story you can
also join the conversation on twitter
our handle is at aj inside story from me
kim vanel and the whole team here in
doha bye for now
[Music]